foreign
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this session we will learn about the
temp tables and SQL but before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple Technologies if
you're a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological Trends then
consider clicking subscribe to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn now without further
Ado let's get started with a one point
agenda that is 10 tables in SQL
so what exactly are temp tables in SQL
so temp table is a temporary table so
the term temporary is self-explanatory
you know that every database and SQL has
Stables right now let's say you created
10 tables in your database and you close
your MySQL workbench or you close your
database and you restart it after a
while and then you will have all your 10
tables intact in your database but
temporary table is not like that it is
something different which has its
existence until the session of the
database is running let's say you open
the database now you have this session
of database running you created the 11th
table as a temporary table and that
particular 11th temporary table will be
existing in the database only until the
current database is running and active
once you close it once you turn it off
or once you restart it the temporary
11th table that you created will type or
it will be eliminated so that is the
meaning of temp table now let's see how
we can create a temporary table
so the syntax is completely similar to
the temporary or to the table what we
usually create right is similar to the
table what we regularly create but the
only catches we will be using the
keyword temporary
create temporary table table name which
is user defined name and inside that the
parameters may be the employee ID
student IDM planning student ready name
Etc right so this is how we create the
temporary table now let's quickly get
back to the simple web page and try to
create a temporary table add some data
into it and try to display the temporary
table if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now we are back on the SQL workbench
and meanwhile we are logging in
you might have a question right
when you say that the temp table will be
existing or running only until the
database is active then why create those
temporary tables in the workbench right
the sole purpose of using temporary
tables is
in a few cases the intermediate results
of the data analytics process are
important and you can have a quick
reference on intermediate results and
you don't want them to be existing in
your database in a permanent basis right
for such scenarios you can use a
temporary database now here on my
workbench we have a simple code for
creating a temporary table so I'll be
creating the temporary table on the name
of student and we have student ID
integer data type student name worker
and department and student ID will be
the primary key now let's use the
database that is use simple and database
to get access and we have the access num
let's quickly see what and all tables we
have using the show command
enter
and we have two tables employee and
employ table two but not student
right now let's quickly execute this
control enter
and now let's use the insert command
same like we inserted in the previous
tables insert into table name student
parameters ID name department and values
comma separated values student ID name
and departmental Group whatever he took
in college
right now let's execute this code
the data has been successfully included
now let's Select Staff from Sprint that
is view the contents in this particular
table we have the values in this
particular table and let's also see if
we have that particular data included in
the database or not let us show tables
there you go it's not included in the
database but it is active when you try
to you know print the values in that
particular table which is in the
database it will show you but when you
try to fetch that particular existence
or the permanent existence of that
particular table it will not be present
and this particular table will be active
only until the database is active now
let's restart this particular work which
I'm closing it
restarting it
now if I run this I will not get it you
can see the error the database
right okay then let's have the database
selected
and let's try to run the command
there you go
table simply learn DB dot student does
not exist
right
previously when you try to execute the
table was giving us values now we have
the error saying the table does not
exist right that is how temporary
database runs now with that we have come
to an end of this session on temp tables
in SQL if you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in this
session or if you require the resources
that we used maybe PPT or demo code then
do letters in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to resolve all your queries
at the earliest until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign